From modern masterpieces to cult classics, these
frightful films never got a sequel or remake.
"Help!"
"Jay what is it?"
The central theme of the 2010 South Korean
horror movie I Saw the Devil is the price of
obsessive revenge. After government operative
Kim Soo-hyun — played by Lee Byung-hun — loses
his pregnant fiancée to Choi Min-sik's Jang
Kyung-chul, he swears vengeance and vows to
pick apart the mass murderer's entire
life. Even as Jang adds more victims,
Kim deliberately lets him walk free so
he can continue to stalk and torment him.
The Los Angeles Times praised I Saw the Devil
for balancing its bloody mayhem with a realistic
emotional undercurrent — its tragedy sets
the movie apart from typical horror films.
In Paste's retrospective review, they claimed
the film's violent meditation on revenge was
criminally overlooked during its initial release,
and declared it the best horror movie from 2010.
According to The Wrap, the English-language remake
rights to I Saw the Devil were optioned in 2013,
with writers Simon Barrett and Adam Wingard
set to tackle the adaptation. However,
nothing has come of the project yet. In 2021,
Barrett told iHorror.com that
it's probably for the best saying,
"Even though it would have been
much different than the original,
it would have just probably annoyed some people"
Long before he helmed The Lord of
the Rings trilogy or King Kong,
Peter Jackson crafted low-budget horror
comedies in his native New Zealand. Among
the most notorious of Jackson's early work is the
1992 zombie movie, Braindead. Released in North
America as Dead Alive, the hilarious cult classic
is considered one of the goriest films ever made.
"I kick ass for the lord!"
Those bitten by a plague-ridden
rat-monkey from Skull Island at
the Wellington Zoo become feral
and rise as ravenous zombies.
Timothy Balme's Lionel tries to
keep the undead outbreak a secret,
even as the number of zombies grows
after his mother Vera becomes infected.
With nearly 80 gallons of fake blood
reportedly used for the climactic sequence,
Braindead is Jackson at his most gruesome.
While Jackson told Uproxx that he's working
on a 4K re-mastering of Braindead, that's
about the extent of anything that's
currently happening with the title.
Following an acclaimed career as the
co-creator and co-star of the sketch
comedy series Key & Peele, Jordan Peele
turned his attention to horror. Peele made
his feature debut with 2017's Get Out, acting
as writer, director, and producer for the film.
The film follows Chris Washington, played by
Daniel Kaluuya, as he travels with his girlfriend,
played by Allison Williams, to meet her family
in upstate New York. Shortly after arriving,
Chris discovers that the community harbors a
dark secret and that he's the next
target for their insidious goals.
"Get out!"
"Sorry, man."
"Okay."
"Get out!"
"Yo!"
"Now."
"Yo. Chill, man."
"Get out!"
Peele's story is filled with sharp
satire and biting social commentary
about the Black experience in the United
States. Named one of the best horror
films of all time by Rotten Tomatoes, the
movie was a major critical and commercial
success. The film even won Peele an
Oscar for Best Original Screenplay.
Peele told Business Insider that Get
Out was the first of five socially
conscious horror movies he
planned on making, saying,
"I've been working on these premises
about these different social demons,
these innately human monsters that are woven into
the fabric of how we think and how we interact."
Peele's second horror feature, Us, hit
theaters in 2019. His third effort,
Nope, came out in 2022. While these movies
have common social commentaries, to date,
they're all considered stand-alone entries.
There are currently no plans to revisit Get Out.
Drew Goddard and Joss Whedon — who had
previously collaborated on Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and Angel — reunited for the
critically-acclaimed 2011 feature film, The
Cabin in the Woods. Goddard directed, with Whedon
producing a screenplay that they wrote together.
The Cabin in the Woods sees a group of college
students vacationing at a remote cabin,
only to be unwittingly targeted by a
cabal of scientists. The scientists
must complete a supernatural
ritual to stop the apocalypse,
so they unleash a number of common horror
movie monsters to prey upon the students.
The Cabin in the Woods leans
into its self-aware storytelling,
poking fun about established horror tropes
while subverting audience expectations. In
an interview with Total Film, Whedon referred
to the movie as "a very loving hate letter."
Although the ending doesn't leave
much to follow up with for a sequel,
that's never stopped a horror franchise
before. However, Goddard told Fandango,
"Every version of continuing the story undercuts
the ending that we had in Cabin, and I just feel
like that continues to be the perfect ending
for that movie and I never want to undercut it."
Though filmmaker Paul W.S. Anderson may be
best known for helming most of the Resident
Evil movies, his finest horror movie is
arguably 1997's Event Horizon. Combining
science fiction with supernatural horror, Event
Horizon sees a group of astronauts becoming the
victims of a spaceship possessed by demonic
forces. In a behind-the-scenes feature on
the Event Horizon DVD, producer Jeremy Bolt
described the film as a ghost story in space.
"She tore a hole in our universe.
A gateway to another dimension."
Though not financially or critically
successful during its theatrical release,
Event Horizon found greater success in the home
video market and has since become a bonafide
cult classic. In an interview with Inverse about
the move, Anderson remembered a piece of advice
actor Kurt Russell gave him in the wake of the
movie's disappointing initial run. Russel said,
"In 20 years, that's going to be the
movie you're really glad you made"
It seems the actor was right.
While Variety reported in
2019 that a television series
adaptation was in the works,
there hasn't been any further information
released about a possible follow-up.
From Doctor Sleep to Midnight Mass, Mike Flanagan
has become one of the most celebrated horror
filmmakers to emerge in recent years. One of
Flanagan's earliest features — which he directed,
edited, and co-wrote — was the 2013
supernatural horror movie, Oculus.
Kaylie and Tim — played by Karen
Gillan and Brenton Thwaites,
respectively — are siblings investigating
the cursed legacy of a haunted mirror that
destroyed their family when they were children.
The story unfolds across two time periods,
moving between their childhood trauma
and their present-day investigation.
Many of Flanagan's narrative themes seen in his
acclaimed Netflix original series, The Haunting of
Hill House, are prominently on display in Oculus
— most notably, the end of childhood innocence.
In 2014, Flanagan talked to JoBlo about the
possibility of a sequel. While he noted that
he'd be interested in doing one if he found an
exciting story, he had no real interest, saying,
"The last thing I'd want to do is
get in the business of franchising
the movie and crank out sequels
to an idea even if it's worn out."
Grief and the loss of family run heavy through
the Australian horror movie The Babadook,
written and directed by Jennifer Kent
in her feature directorial debut.
In the wake of losing her husband, Essie
Davis's Amelia struggles to raise her young
son Samuel — played by Noah Wiseman.
This is complicated further when the
two are menaced by a supernatural
creature known as the Babadook.
Kent strove to utilize practical effects
throughout the entire production. As
Amelia and Samuel are both poisoned by their
grief, Kent's special effects choices augment
the film's theme of how people create
monsters from their personal darkness.
"You don't know how many times I
wished it was you, not him, that died."
The Babadook is truly one of a kind,
and Kent knows this better than anyone. In an
interview with IGN, she claimed that she owns
the film's sequel rights to ensure that
one will never be made. She elaborated,
"It's just not what the film's
about. It would destroy the
integrity of everything we
worked so hard to protect."
Sex and death walk hand-in-hand in the 2014 indie
horror flick, It Follows — written and directed
by David Robert Mitchell. The movie involves a
sexually-transmitted supernatural entity and the
variety of forms it utilizes to close in on its
prey. Jay Height — played by Maika Monroe — is
the latest person to receive this curse and
searches for a way to escape her grim fate.
It Follows received considerable critical
acclaim upon its theatrical release in 2015,
with the Rotten Tomatoes critical
consensus describing it as,
"Smart, original, and above all
terrifying, It Follows is the rare
modern horror film that works on multiple
levels — and leaves a lingering sting."
With its steady escalation of suspense
interwoven with its narrative themes,
It Follows became a solid success, with Monroe
specifically lauded for her performance. According
to Entertainment Weekly, though there was some
talk of a follow-up to It Follows in 2015,
there has been little information about
any project development since then.
Mitchell told Digital Spy that he does have
some ideas of where the story could go,
but for now he wants to keep it as a standalone.
A24 is an independent entertainment company
that has achieved a lot of acclaim since its
launch in 2012. For over a decade,
the studio has been releasing many
horror film favorites, like Under the
Skin, The Witch, and 2018's Hereditary.
Hereditary marked the feature directorial
debut of Ari Aster. Throughout the film,
Aster, who also wrote the screenplay, explores
the dissolution of a family in the face of
immense grief. Hereditary begins with a grounded,
relatable tragedy before steadily progressing into
outright supernatural terror. After the Graham
family loses their young daughter in a horrific
accident, they become targets of a sinister group
involved with demons and malevolent spirits.
"And look at that pattern. Did you see up there?
This was painted above the body, right? In blood!"
The film is a searing look at a divided
family, manipulated by forces beyond
their comprehension. It's hard to imagine a
follow-up when Hereditary's stunning finale
ends quite conclusively, so perhaps it's for
the best that the story remains untouched.
Channeling the aesthetics and styles of
1980s horror, The House of the Devil is
one of the earliest feature films written
and directed by acclaimed filmmaker Ti
West. According to The Independent, West's
quest for authenticity came right down to the
director shooting the movie on 16mm film
and releasing promotional copies on VHS.
College student Samantha Hughes, played
by Jocelin Donahue, answers a call for a
babysitting gig at a remote mansion, only to
learn that the job is not exactly what was
advertised. Samantha soon finds herself
in the middle of an occult ritual after
discovering the true occupants of the house
were gruesomely murdered by her employers.
More than just wearing his influences on his
sleeve, West subverts expectations about the
genre to keep the audience on its toes, while
building the tension and violence in equal
measure. A love letter to '80s horror
— right down to its commentary on the
satanic panic — The House of the Devil features
West's filmmaking strengths on full display.
The New York Times sang its praises for the
film, saying that West's use of setting and
suspense holds up against works by legendary
filmmakers years his senior. As West has become
more widely known for his recent movie trilogy of
X, its prequel Pearl, and the upcoming MaXXXine,
he seems to have left The House of
the Devil to stand on its own for now.
Canadian filmmaker David Cronenberg is widely
recognized as the master of body horror, with his
1983 film Videodrome being one of the standouts of
his career. Along with Cronenberg's signature gore
and grotesque body transformations, Videodrome
tackles mass media consumption — specifically,
how the rising UHF television stations
of the time addressed sex and violence.
The film focuses on cable station CEO Max Renn
— played by James Woods — as he begins airing
Videodrome, a program from Malaysia that
allegedly consists of actual snuff films.
After Nicki Brand — played by Debbie Harry —
becomes obsessed with the program and vanishes,
Max learns that Videodrome actually airs
from Pittsburgh. He decides to investigate
further and discovers a surreal and
strange world he never imagined.
"Television is reality, and
reality is less than television."
Videodrome is a surreal exploration
of the infectious impact that media
consumption has on the subconscious,
standing out among Cronenberg's
most acclaimed films. Paste even
called it his best movie, writing,
"Videodrome is horror down to its bones,
a shard of phantasmagorical mania wielded
by the genre's most cerebral master."
Back in 2012, Deadline announced that Adam
Berg would direct a remake of Videodrome,
modernizing the story as a big budget sci-fi
action thriller. As of January 2023, no further
information on this remake has been released,
and Cronenberg's classic has remained untouched.
If the 1973 classic British film The Wicker
Man originally popularized the idea of folk
horror movies, 2019's Midsommar updated the
sub-genre with modern sensibilities and a
bigger body count. Written and directed
by Ari Aster, the movie takes place in
the middle of a summertime celebration in
scenic Sweden. With its sun-soaked setting
and cheerful residents, Midsommar is a
thoroughly memorable take on the genre.
In the traumatizing aftermath
of losing her entire family,
Florence Pugh's Dani travels with her boyfriend
and their friends to a midsummer festival in
Sweden. The group discovers a strange commune
behind the celebration, with bizarre customs
and rituals designed to rob individuals of
their sanity, and eventually their lives.
Aster told Fandango that since they share
some themes, Midsommar can be seen as,
quote, "something of a companion to
Hereditary." However, both of these
two are ultimately stand-alone, and to date,
no followup to Midsommar has been announced.
Robert Eggers' feature film debut, 2015's The
Witch, captured the grim side of early America,
effectively blending folk and supernatural
horror. Growing up in New Hampshire,
Eggers was fascinated by the local folklore
fostered by the region's history of witch
trials. Discussing his goals for the
film with The Atlantic, Eggers said,
"I wanted to make an archetypal
New England horror story,
something that would feel like an inherited
nightmare, a Puritan nightmare from the past."
Eggers put his childhood fears into a story
about isolation and being shunned from society,
causing his protagonists to fall prey to
the horrors existing on the fringe. Set
in New England during the 1630s, The Witch
follows a small English family when they
are banished from their Puritanical colony
for a religious falling out. As they attempt
to run their own homestead, their crops
fail in the face of the impending winter,
and they are targeted by a local witch
working to tear the entire family apart.
"You cannot bring the crops to yield.
You cannot hunt. Is that truth enough?"
"Enough."
"Thou canst do nothing save cut wood!"
Using only natural and period-appropriate
light, The Witch is arguably Eggers at his
most atmospheric and unsettling. While outlets
like Rotten Tomatoes named it the best horror
film of 2016, Eggers told Entertainment Weekly
that he has no plans for a sequel. He stated,
"If I wanted to know what happens
after the last shot of the film,
I would have made a longer movie."
One of the most influential visionaries
in horror films is Italian filmmaker Dario
Argento. His early work in the giallo subgenre
has inspired countless storytellers across
a variety of mediums and earned him great
praise from critics. Garage even called him,
quote, "the most influential horror
director outside of Hitchcock."
Argento's 1985 film Phenomena follows
Jennifer, played by Jennifer Connelly,
who travels to a remote all-girls boarding
school in Switzerland. While there, she uses
her powers to communicate with insects to stop a
serial killer preying on women around the school.
Phenomena combined supernatural horror with the
classic giallo trappings of mystery plots with
slasher and psychological thriller elements. With
Argento's usual flair for hyper-stylized visuals,
and a set of insects and arachnids
to match the film's creepy themes,
Phenomena stands among
Argento's most beloved works.
Though the original international cut of the film
was a heavily edited version titled Creepers,
Argento fans can see all versions of
the film rendered in 4K Ultra HD in
the upcoming 2023 home release by Synapse Films.
While this cult classic went
nearly 40 years without a sequel,
that may change soon. In 2022, the Italian
studio Titanus announced that it had plans
to make a sequel to Phenomena set in
the modern day with a mix of U.S. and
international talents. The film was
in development as of October of 2022.
Adam Wingard's 2014 horror film The Guest
centers around the Peterson family mourning
the loss of their son Caleb in the War in
Afghanistan. They're unexpectedly visited
by former U.S. soldier David Collins,
played by Dan Stevens, who claims to
have been Caleb's best friend overseas. As
the Petersons welcome David into their home,
increasingly violent acts begin to
occur around the family. David is at
the center of this lethal escalation, which
leads them to wonder about his identity.
"If you brought money for all of them, I'll cut
you a deal. You can take them all off my hands."
"No, I'm going to kill you."
Driven by a darkly charming performance from
Stevens, The Guest doesn't necessarily surprise
its audience with twists, but it still
manages to be a captivating thrill-ride.
Beloved by critics upon its release,
it has become a cult hit over time.
In 2021, screenwriter Simon Barrett told
ComicBook.com that a potential follow-up would
go in a radically different direction because
he never intended to make a sequel for the film.
Wingard confirmed in 2022 just how different
that direction would be when he released The
Guest 2 as a musical soundtrack. In
a press release, Wingard explained,
"Embedded within the song
titles, the album artwork,
and the music itself are hidden clues that lead
the listener down the path a sequel would take."
In an interview with Empire, Wingard
noted that working on the soundtrack
inspired him and Barrett, and they're
now considering an actual film or TV
sequel to The Guest. However, there's no
word yet on if they'll go ahead with it.
One of the most chilling movies to come
out of South Korea is Na Hong-jin's The
Wailing. Channeling a mix of horror movie
influences, the 2016 film blends everything
from body horror and demonic possession to
ghost stories and sociopolitical commentary.
After a mysterious Japanese man — played by Jun
Kunimura — visits a small South Korean town,
its inhabitants suddenly become enraged and
kill their own families. As two police officers
investigate what happened, suspecting the Japanese
man as the culprit, they soon find that there are
paranormal forces at work. The Wailing received
near-universal critical acclaim upon its release,
due largely to its haunting atmosphere
and an unforgettably bleak ending.
In 2017, ScreenDaily reported that Ridley Scott
was interested in producing an English-language
remake. However, producer Hosung Kim noted
that the setting and sensibility of The
Wailing would be difficult to translate into
a Western remake. Though Hosung and Na weren't
completely opposed to the idea, there's
been no word of the reboot since then.
Starting with The Thing in 1982, celebrated
filmmaker John Carpenter launched his
Apocalypse Trilogy — a set of standalone
movies that conclude with certain doom for
the human race. The second installment of
this informal trilogy is 1987's Prince of
Darkness. The film is directed by Carpenter
from a screenplay he wrote under a pseudonym,
and it focuses on the arrival of Satan on Earth.
"Pray for death."
A quantum physicist and his team are invited to
inspect a strange liquid that they're informed is
Satan. The liquid begins to infect and possess
the researchers, with the scientists deducing
from their recurring dreams that they are
facing an antimatter-fueled apocalypse.
According to Film Cred,
"The concepts behind Prince of Darkness came from
Carpenter’s interest in the utterly
uncanny world of quantum physics."
Prince of Darkness sees Carpenter at his
most surreal, with audiences and critics
marking it among his most underrated works.
Carpenter told Consequence of Sound in 2018
that he was considering turning Prince of
Darkness into a TV series with Shudder. He
further explained to Fandom in 2022 that
he's open to making a sequel to the movie
because of the many fun directions they
could go with its subject matter. However,
no official plans have been
made for a sequel or series.
Spanish filmmaker J.A. Bayona leaned heavily into
classic horror influences for
their 2007 film, The Orphanage.
Belén Rueda's Laura returns to
the orphanage where she grew up
with the intention of reopening it as a
children's clinic. Her plans get thwarted
when her adopted son — played by Roger Princep
— goes missing. As Laura searches for her son,
she discovers the orphanage harbors a dark
secret and a haunted legacy of its own.
Screenwriter Sergio G. Sanchez told The Deadbolt
that his main influences in crafting the story
were literary works: J.M. Barrie's Peter
Pan inspired him to imagine the story of
a runaway child like Wendy Darling from a
parent's perspective, while Henry James' The
Turn of the Screw gave him the framework for a
child-centered ghost story full of adult themes.
The Orphanage was a critical
and box office hit in 2007,
becoming the highest-grossing movie in
Spain. Not surprisingly, an American
remake was almost immediately announced in that
same year. However, there has been little news
surrounding the proposed project since 2011,
when it was reported on by Bloody Disgusting.
The final horror movie that Dario Argento directed
in the '80s, 1987's Opera, stands among his best.
Released on American home video as Terror at
the Opera, the film is centered on a young
opera singer — played by Cristina Marsillach
— finally getting her big break to headline
an Italian opera. Her dreams are crushed
when a horrific killing spree breaks out
in the opera house, with the murders
resembling the traumatizing death of
her mother years prior. She then sets out
to discover the masked killer's identity.
After numerous projects exploring the
supernatural, Argento returned to his more
grounded giallo roots for Opera. A gruesome
murder mystery, Opera is one of Argento's
most critically-acclaimed films, with Slant
calling it "his last full-fledged masterpiece."
Slick and stylish, Opera demonstrates
how far Argento had grown as a filmmaker,
setting a high-water mark for the giallo
subgenre that has seemingly yet to be
surpassed. This may also be part of the reason
why no one has tried to remake or revisit it.